so the premise of this movie is you come
then it follows it follows so it follows
is a low-budget horror movie usually
those are terrible because low-budget
horror movies are easy to make so
someone's gonna make it's gonna have a
lot of jump scares gonna cost 5 bucks to
make it's gonna make millions of dollars
who's gonna get a sequel so now we have
it follows which is a smart low-budget
horror movie everyone on lines like this
is scary [ __ ] ever I'm never gonna sleep
again ever felt like that I mean it was
good but it wasn't look too scary should
have ever seen definitely had a lot more
brains going for than a lot of other
horror movies low-budget and otherwise
and I've seen lately anyway so what it
follows is from the trailer so it's not
really spoiler ish there's this girl
she's a nice girl she's an average girl
what I liked about her she wasn't like
the [ __ ] girl usually in horror movies
like this you have all these really
super sexy model type teenage chicks and
they're gonna get terrorized by this -
evil whatever this girl at one point man
she was rocking the granny panties she
had straight-up
white cotton granny panties I was like
good for you but she's nice she's
average she just she's a cute girl but
she is just she's not a [ __ ] she
means it's one dude she really likes and
then one night skin on skin that love
began and then he's like okay now this
demon things going to follow you this
thing never runs it just walks it walks
towards her and she just has to not get
touched by is pretty much like a shitty
game of tag which now that you know the
premise go back listen to the intro this
video now you'll get it I was really
impressed with this movie crammed do
this movie doesn't always move it's not
like this fast-paced adrenaline rush
because it can be because the premise is
this thing is walking towards this girl
for the entire movie if it's as
high-octane adrenaline rush for the
entire experience it's gonna completely
compromise it you're not gonna feel
vulnerable this movie takes place in the
in-between moments the moments when
you're running from something you sit
down to catch your breath you're like
alright I just want to stop running for
a second let's just stop running and you
get comfortable before you know it it
follows it was great it gives you
perpetual anxiety put your anxiety up
there it's like yeah right now just go
ahead and hold that for an hour and a
half it was like the premise that the
first Paranormal Activity before the
franchise became [ __ ] there are people
who argue that the franchise was always
[ __ ] I'm just saying that first movie
gave you anxiety because you're like I
don't feel safe um I God know there
no kind of what this feels like it's not
a found footage movie for those you're
going to ask from the comment section
it's not it's actually a movie a movie
that's like a really sweet 1979 horror
movie that was filmed in 2014 or 13
released in 2015
kind of harken back to Friday the 13th
with Jason Voorhees or Michael Myers I
just walk at you is freaky when
something walks at you and then wins
because when it wins you just feel like
you completely failed you're like how
can something that only walks beat me
even the soundtrack of this movie man
sounded like 1979 horror yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum the bummer is I've heard
nothing but the fact that this is a
scariest movie that's ever made for the
past couple weeks so is it over - ow
yeah it's completely over hi that's not
really a negative though overhyped just
means overhyped it doesn't mean bad I
mean if someone was like hey how is Lord
of the Rings I'll be like it's great and
overhyped along with Empire Strikes Back
yeah that's great and overhyped - at a
point there's nothing can really live up
to the praise that it's getting at a
point just anything can become over
height that's not a fault on the things
just something you should be aware is it
the scariest movie ever no I wish I was
more scared in this movie granted I
haven't slept yet night time has not
befallen me since I've seen this movie
so hey tomorrow morning I may be
tweeting like help me I'm sucking my
thumb
lol emote I don't know but more or less
I was really interested in this movie I
love the fact that this movie takes you
along the ride with this girl you feel
what she feels you're on edge anytime
you see anybody walking in this movie
you're like is that it is that the is
that the thing is that the thing so guys
it follows is a really refreshing take
on the horror movie genre it's not the
same old same old popcorn flick kind of
thing you know you're not gonna just go
like I love horror movies I love slasher
movies hey my gore fiend I love Rob
Zombie movies I'm in it to win it now if
you like that you're probably gonna
watch this and be bored shitless because
it does have that low-budget artsy twang
to it too but in the end this movie kept
me engaged I was invested I was
interested I will say it follows is
certainly a good time no alcohol
required this movie's pretty much like
the embodiment of a really shitty STD
like demonic herpes really yeah bang you
get it and once in a while this thing
will show up to cause problems it'll die
down you'll get away from it and you'll
just come back there's a thing you
always have right so it follows have you
seen it what did you think about it
really curious about this one's whatever
you thought comment below let me
now and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more